[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute
puddingplunder ich finde alles was mit
Hefeteig und Vanillepudding zu tun hat
schmeckt einfach immer richtig gut ich
starte direkt mit dem Rezept ihr findet
wie immer alle ganz genauen
Mengenangaben hier unten in der Infobox
und ich starte jetzt hier mit meinem
Mehl ich habe hier die volle Ladung 500
g ich werde aber nicht alles reingeben
denn wenn ihr einmal zu viel Mehl in den
Hefeteig gibt dann ist es meistens schon
zu spät daher also nachgeben kann man
immer daher so ein bisschen was zur
Seite legen jetzt kommt natürlich auch
immer das Volumen der Eier an wie viele
da benötigt da gebe ich jetzt
Trockenhefe mit dazu ihr könnt auch
frische Hefe verwenden die dann in die
lauwarme Milch gleich einarbeiten falls
ihr frische Hefe verwenden würde aber
Trockenhefe habe ich zum Beispiel immer
da und dann könnt ihr auch schon die
nächste trockene Zutat dazu geben das
wäre dann Zucker
und ich gebe noch eine sehr sehr gute
Prise Salz mit rein einfach weil das
noch mal den süßen Geschmack ein
bisschen hebt das verrühre ich jetzt
einmal kurz mit dem Schneebesen damit es
sich gut verbindet dann wird da einfach
eine Mulde ich habe einfach saubere
Hände heute nehme ich nicht die
Küchenmaschine sonst mache ich das gerne
da bin ich ganz ehrlich mit euch aber
ich wollte euch einfach zeigen dass es
auch mit den Händen geht so da kommt
jetzt lauwarme Milch mit rein
und Öl dann nehmt ihr einfach ein
neutrales entweder Sonnenblumen oder
Rapsöl es gibt nämlich mit dazu und wenn
ich nichts für die Eier okay die Eier
gebe ich noch mit dazu dann nehme ich
aber jetzt nicht alles sondern nur das
Eiweiß das Eigelb heben wir uns auf eins
für den Vanillepudding und das andere
zum bestreichen und Eiweiß macht den
Hefeteig auch noch mal so ein bisschen
fluffiger daher verwerte ich das einfach
und gibt das hier mit rein und danach
könnt ihr aber kneten
[Musik]
beim Hefeteig kneten mache ich so dass
ich mir zwischendrin während ich knete
einmal die Hände waschen muss damit
wieder alles auf Reset ist und ich den
Teig so ein bisschen besser fühlen kann
und dann gebe ich das ähm also jetzt auf
die Arbeitsfläche persönlich finde es
dann im Anschluss so ein bisschen
einfacher als jetzt in der weiter zu
kneten und gebe dann wirklich immer nur
purple ein bisschen Mehl mit dazu denn
wenn ihr zu viel Mehl dazu gibt dann ist
es einfach zu trocken und wenn sich das
sage ich immer wieder in meine Hefeteig
wie du es aber in dem Fall ist es wieder
so wenn sich euer Hefeteig wie euer
Ohrläppchen anfühlt einfach mal fühlen
also es ist komplett identisch richtig
crazy äh dann ist er fertig der darf
ganz leicht also er klebt nicht mehr so
wirklich sondern ja so minimal also man
hat das Gefühl okay ganz ganz leicht
vielleicht noch aber jetzt nicht so dass
da irgendwie noch mehr fehlt oder das
super super klebrig ist und ich nehme
jetzt hier noch mein backtrennspray weil
ich jetzt auch nicht zusätzlich unnötig
viel Mehl noch mal in meine Schüssel und
auf den Teig geben möchte weil ob man
will oder nicht das arbeitet sich ja
auch in den Hefeteig ein so jetzt schön
luftdicht verschließen und wenn ihr Zeit
habt eine Stunde gehen lassen wenn ihr
keine Zeit habt dann 45 Minuten auch
okay an einem warmen Ort wo kein
Durchzug herrscht so wir machen jetzt in
der Zwischenzeit schon mal unsere
Pudding Füllung die darf dann nämlich
anschließend auch abkühlen und zwar
haben wir hier Milch habe ich jetzt
nicht alles in meinen Topf er hat es
noch ausgeschaltet ein bisschen was so
um die kann ich kann so schlecht
schätzen so um die 67 Esslöffel dass ich
mir jetzt hier noch beiseite da rühre
ich jetzt Speisestärke ein das ist so
ein bisschen wie ihr kennt das doch wenn
ihr auch fertigen Vanillepuddingpulver
kauft dann ist es doch auch so dass man
das Pulver erst so ein bisschen in die
Milch einrührt das hilft einfach dass
sich das später besser verbindet und ihr
das nicht zu schnell erwärmt und dann
Klümpchen erhaltet ähm das ist übrigens
super super tolle Wahl jeweils ich weiß
nicht ob man sieht aber ich versuche es
jetzt und zu kleckern hier rein zu
bekommen beim Backen ist natürlich ganz
wichtig dass ihr jetzt nicht so viele
nebenkleckert weil da ist jetzt der
Gramm genau abgewogen
so den Rest hole ich mir jetzt gleich
einen Teigschaber noch raus ich kann ja
schon mal für euch weitermachen und da
kommt jetzt noch das Eigelb mit rein das
hat sich jetzt hier so ein bisschen
verfangen das eine Eigelb ist ein
bisschen zerlaufen aber es nehme ich mir
einfach raus es kommt hier mit rein
macht was mit der Konsistenz und ihr
bekommt diese typische
vanillepuddingfarbe das verrühren wir
hier einfach vorab Klümpchen frei und
ihr könnt jetzt hier zum Topf schon mal
Vanilleextrakt geben ich weiß es ja
Vanillepudding also da nicht geizen
wobei das schon sehr hoch konzentriert
ist so Vanilleextrakt ist drin und
Zucker für die Süße und dann wird es
einfach nur erwärmt ihr merkt es auch
wenn er so ganz kleine Bläschen sind es
wird dann schön warm und dann gibt ihr
einfach hier unser Gemisch mit dazu das
müsstet ihr kurz vorher auch noch mal
verrühren weil in den 12 Minuten wo die
Milch erwärmt wird wird es ja auch noch
mal also die Stärke setzt sich dann auch
schon wieder auf dem Boden ab daher kurz
vorher am besten auch noch mal rühren
und damit dazugeben
[Musik]
den Pudding dann unter ständigem Rühren
einmal aufkochen lassen dann merkt ihr
auch schon wie schnell der ein liegt ich
habe das jetzt hier schon direkt
umgefüllt und direkt an der Oberfläche
mit Frischhaltefolie abdecken damit wir
keine Haut haben es soll ja Menschen
geben die mögen puddinghaut was wir bis
heute ein Rätsel ist aber es brauchen
wir in diesem Fall wirklich nicht so das
lasse ich jetzt auch kurz abkühlen dann
warten auf den Hefeteig und dann geht's
weiter so die Ruhezeit ist vorbei der
Hefeteig wird jetzt in acht gleichmäßig
große Teiglinge geteilt
oh das ist richtig fluffig der Teig und
ich mache das jetzt einfach ja nach
Gefühl ich kann jetzt auch eine Waage
nehmen und das alles gleichmäßig viel
wiegt aber ich finde das geht jetzt auch
ganz gut mit der Teigkarte hier einfach
in der Mitte dann noch mal jeweils in
der Mitte und dann noch mal in der Mitte
und dann haben wir acht Teiglinge der
Rest ist jetzt sehr sehr easy wir werden
die Teiglinge hier jetzt zu Kugeln
formen also ich nehme mir dann immer mit
dem Teil von außen und ziehen so in die
Mitte bis ich eine eine Form habe und
dann mache ich entweder in den
Handinnenflächen das ganze noch mal
Kugel rund oder ihr legt das mit der
unschönen Seite nach unten auf die
Arbeitsfläche und dann könnt ihr das in
der Hand im Handballen quasi so ein
bisschen hin und her rollen und dann
habt ihr quasi eine wunderschöne Kugel
die geben jetzt direkt auf unser
Backblech und dort darf das dann auch
noch mal 10 Minuten entspannen das war's
[Musik]
so nach 10 Minuten Entspannung unterm
Tuch ganz ganz wichtig sonst trocknen
sie nämlich aus können wir schon
weitermachen und zwar mache ich jetzt so
dass einfach mit den Fingern noch mal
erstmal flach andrücken und dann nehme
ich mir ein Glas also irgendwas rundes
was ihr da habt und dann geht ihr dann
noch mal richtig rein
ruhig mit ein bisschen Druck wenn ihr
merkt dass der Teig sich wieder
zusammenzieht hat er sich noch nicht
genug entspannt dann könnt ihr einfach
noch mal mit dem Tuch abdecken lassen
aber so passt es jetzt bei mir und da
kommt gleich
regelmäßig gleichmäßig unser Pudding
rein und den Ofen nämlich auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 170 Grad Umluft weil ich
möchte gerne zwei Bleche gleichzeitig
backen sonst könnt ihr auch 180 Grad
Ober und Unterhitze nehmen dadurch dass
wir jetzt auch bei Umluft Backen Leute
es ist umso wichtiger dass ihr das
Hefegebäck mit dem Eigelb bestreicht
weil sonst wird es total trocken weil
Umluft der lässt ja noch mal das Blätter
noch mal Luft in den Ofen und ich möchte
ja nicht dass das trocken mit dem
Gegenteil das soll ja schön fluffig
schminken und äh da wirkt ja einfach
entgegen und außerdem macht es halt noch
mal wirklich eine schöne Bräune
[Musik]
so bei mir haben die Plunderteilchen
jetzt 18 bzw 19 Minuten gebraucht also
schaut nach 18 Minuten mal ob sie braun
genug sind sie sollten nicht zu dunkel
werden und jetzt sind die bei mir
abgekühlt bzw ganz ganz leicht minimal
war noch und ich gebe jetzt Puderzucker
oben drauf und dann ist das Rezept auch
schon fertig ich muss sagen das ging
echt schnell das staunt mich gerade ein
bisschen ich habe das nämlich lange
nicht mehr gemacht und doch ja ich
brauche jetzt eine Weile aber das ging
echt klar so dann sehen wir uns gleich
zum Test wieder
[Musik]
genug ich habe die puddingteilchen ich
habe einen Cappuccino hier ist sogar
noch so ein halbherziges Herz drauf also
ich habe es nicht verlernt und jetzt
gönne ich mich ich weiß einfach direkt
rein für euch
lecker kannst du mal ran weil man sieht
so richtig die Poren diese Poren ist ein
Traum und genauso wie es aussieht
schmeckt es auch also so richtig von
außen ganz dünn und ganz leicht diese
Kruste aber im positiven Sinne es
schmeckt super gut dann beißt ihr euch
in diesem warmen Hefeteig also hier ist
bei mir noch lauwarm und der ist ultra
fluffig die schmecken auch kalt aber ich
gebe euch einen Tipp ihr könnt sie auch
am nächsten Tag z.B ein paar Sekunden in
der Mikrowelle erwärmen und eigentlich
muss ich mich jetzt noch durch diesen
Pudding Kern beißen auch das mache ich
jetzt auch noch ich es euch jetzt ein
Vorbild könnte das auch sofort machen
[Musik]
Leute
macht's nach ich bin der glücklichste
Mensch der Welt ein Cappuccino dabei und
verabschiede mich jetzt von euch und
sage bis zum nächsten mal auf meinem
Kanal lasst ein Abo da Leute wenn ihr
sie schon längst gemacht habt das war
bald mal die 700.000 klein ich habe das
Gefühl ich habe überall Puderzucker auf
jeden Fall wünsche ich euch viel Spaß
beim Nachmachen und sage Tschüss bis zum
nächsten Mal
[Musik]